Hey there, Will Arnett here from SmartList. It's the podcast where Jason Bateman, Sean Hayes and I interview somebody. Two of us don't know who that person is because one of us has brought on a surprise guest. That's the whole conceit. I wish I could describe it better, but I'm not that smart. So it's SmartList and it's starting now. We do a little pre-dance, right? We always do a little.
大家好，我是《SmartLess》的威尔·阿奈特。这是一个我和杰森·贝特曼、肖恩·海斯一起采访嘉宾的播客。我们其中两人并不知道来宾是谁，因为其中一人带了一位神秘嘉宾来。这就是整个节目的核心概念。我希望我能把它描述得更好，但我没那么聪明。所以这就是《SmartLess》，现在开始。我们先跳个暖场舞，对吧？我们总会跳一小段。
Yeah, we do a little. So, but have we played that little tune on our podcast yet? We haven't played it on the show yet. We've always done it in the pre-room. That's $5 footlong subway that Will's kind of obsessed with. I'm obsessed with that song. So toe-tappy and I feel like if we just throw it on the podcast a couple of times, we might get some sammies.
对，我们跳一小段。所以，不过我们已经在播客里播放过那个小曲儿了吗？我们还没在节目里播过呢。我们总是在候场室里放。那是威尔有点着迷的赛百味5美元巨无霸三明治广告歌。我超迷那首歌。节奏感太强了，我觉得如果我们在播客里放个几次，我们说不定能拿到一些三明治。
Free sammies, yeah. We might. Yeah. I think it's a big hit with the $5 footlong. And by the way, I'll even take the six inch. That's fine. With a bag of chips and a soda. I'll take that too.
免费三明治，对。说不定能行。对。我觉得这首5美元巨无霸的歌超受欢迎。顺便说一句，6英寸的我也行。没问题。配一包薯条和一杯苏打水。我也接受。
Boy, if I had a dollar, the number of times I've heard you say that, Will. Then you all take a six inch. I know. Oh, Lord. I know. What are you guys saying? Scotty and I really look forward to our Jeopardy Wheel of Fortune Hour every night. Do you guys watch?
天哪，如果我每次听到你这么说都能有一块钱的话，威尔。然后你们都去买6英寸的。我知道。哦，天哪。我知道。你们在聊什么呢？我和斯科蒂真的很期待每天晚上的《危险边缘》和《财富之轮》时间。你们看吗？
What? Anybody? Oh, 7 and 730? That's for OC. Okay. So, but now listen, I don't watch it, but in my defense is because I haven't given up yet. Yeah.
什么？有人看吗？哦，7点和7点30？那是给奥橘市（OC）的人看的。好吧。所以，不过现在听着，我不看，但我要为自己辩解，因为我还没放弃治疗呢。对。
You watch those two shows in your sweatpants, right? Yeah. Okay. Says the guy. It's still living. Says the guy in PJs. Now, listen, guys, look, that's a, that's a naked knee. You see right there.
你穿着运动裤看那两个节目，对吧？对。好吧。这话从一个穿着睡衣的人嘴里说出来。还在过日子呢。这话从一个穿着睡衣的人嘴里说出来。现在，听着，伙计们，看，这是一个，这是一个光溜溜的膝盖。你们看那儿。
I've got shorts. I've got shorts on today. I really got shamed. You heard us. You really heard us. You shamed me yesterday. Yeah. Okay.
我穿着短裤。我今天穿着短裤。我真的被羞辱了。你们听见了吧。你们真的听见了吧。你昨天羞辱了我。对。好吧。
So, but wait, but like I'll watch Wheel of Fortune and it'll, you know, that pod, the puzzle would be like, you know, like blank of one half dozen of another. And I'm like, it's six, but then they, they can't ever get it. And I'm yelling at the TV. But then the last puzzle, do you watch Jason for real? I have in the past. Okay. So the last puzzle, now the bonus round, they put two words together that never make any
所以，但是等等，但就像我会看《财富之轮》，然后它会，你知道的，那个拼字谜题会是，你知道的，比如“半斤八两”之类的。然后我在想，是“六”，但接着他们，他们总是猜不出来。我在冲着电视大喊。但最后那个拼字谜题，杰森，你真的看吗？我以前看。好吧。所以最后一个拼字谜题，现在是奖励环节，他们把两个永远不会
sense, right? They'll do like. That I haven't seen. I feel like the phrase is like charred bricks or something, you know, and it's really upsetting, but I got this. This is all moot because you guys don't watch. Well, this, I forget, when did you move to Florida again? I forget this because, and so do you argue with people when you're in line for the early
在一起的词放在一起，对吧？他们会做成那种。那个我没看过。我觉得那个短语听起来像“烧焦的砖头”什么的，你知道的，这真的很让人沮丧，但这个我懂。这都没什么好讨论的，因为你们不看。好吧，这个，我忘了，你是什么时候搬到佛罗里达的来着？我忘了这个，所以你在早鸟餐排队时会和别人吵架吗？
bird? Like what's going on? Yeah. And it's just all you get is basic cable in the trailer. So, so that's why he's watching those game shows. I'm on, I'm on cable, right? So I'm watching MSNBC or things you've got to, um, I just, I, and I say that because my grandparents lived in Florida and my grandmother would talk to the TV and they'd be the stuff
到底怎么回事？对。而且在房车里只能看到基础有线电视。所以，这就是他为什么看那些游戏节目的原因。我在看，我在看有线电视，对吧？所以我看的是MSNBC或者那些你得，呃，我只是，我这么说是因为我祖父母住在佛罗里达，我祖母会对着电视说话，然后就会有各种事情
would be going on. And you're here in the other room, she'd be going, uh-huh. Yeah. Uh-huh. And I'm like, I know she's in there by herself. Hey, is Vanna, is Vanna still out there? Turn in, turn in. She sure is.
正在发生，你在这边的房间里听到她一直在说，“嗯哼。对啊。嗯哼。”我说，我知道她一个人在里面。嘿，瓦娜，瓦娜还在吗？转啊，转。她当然在了。
She's turning lots of letters. Turn in cubes. Yeah. Turn in cubes. Anyway, guys today. Yes. She's a very powerful woman has accomplished more in her few years on this earth than most people have in their entire lifetime.
她正在转好多字母呢。转方块。对。转方块。总之，伙计们，今天。对。她是一个非常强大的女性，在这个地球上短短几年里取得的成就比大多数人一辈子取得的还要多。
She a bodybuilder? Very powerful. Oh, not in that sense. Maybe. No, but she's very much in shape. I'm, I'm pretty confident you guys and our listener will know who she is. She's an Oscar winner, Golden Globe and Emmy winner. If you don't know her or Google her, her name is Reese Witherspoon.
她是健美运动员吗？非常强大。哦，不是那个意思。也许吧。不是，但她身材非常好。我，我很确信你们和我们的听众都会知道她是谁。她是一位奥斯卡奖、金球奖和艾美奖得主。如果你不知道她或没有谷歌搜索她，她的名字叫瑞茜·威瑟斯彭。
What? Oh my gosh. Mrs. America. Wow. Look at her setup. Look at that. I've got, first of all, I've got microphone envy. Wait a minute.
什么？哦，天哪。美国夫人。哇。看看她的装备。看看那个。我，首先，我有麦克风嫉妒症。等等。
Why do you have, it looks like a mic from the 20s. Oh, because that's my other job. She's a time traveler, dum-dum. Just in. That's what it looks like. America's not doing very well. I love a hamburger sandwich. Oh, I'll take that.
为什么你有一个，看起来像是20年代的麦克风？哦，因为那是我的另一份工作。她是个时间旅行者，笨蛋。刚刚发布的。看起来就是这样。美国现在过得不太好。我喜欢汉堡三明治。哦，我要这个。
Oh, Reese. I'm so happy you said yes to stay calm and hang out with us. Wow, you're so sweet to come on. This is huge. Well, long time lister, first time caller. No, you haven't listened any of these. I have. I've been listening, guys.
哦，瑞茜。我太高兴你答应来和我们一起放松闲聊了。哇，你太贴心了能来。这太棒了。嗯，老听众，初次来电。不，你根本没听过这里的任何一集。我听过。我有在听，伙计们。
Really? Yes. You guys are really good guests. Who is your favorite? And I don't mean guests. I don't mean guests. Of the U3. Hosts.
真的吗？对。你们这些嘉宾真的很棒。谁是你的最爱？我不是指嘉宾。我不是指嘉宾。在三人中。主持人。
Wait. She's going to name her favorite. Oh, geez. That's tough. Reese, you're from Nashville, aren't you? That's right. I'm from Nashville, Tennessee. Well, how old were you when you moved out and where did you move to?
等等。她要说出她最喜欢的了。哦，天哪。这太难选了。瑞茜，你是纳什维尔人，对吧？没错。我是田纳西州纳什维尔人。那当你搬出去的时候你多大，你搬到哪里去了？
Straight to LA? Well, let me see. Well, I was an Army, but Air Force brat, actually, so we grew up in all over. Come on. My husband, Scotty, is an Army brat. Grew up in like 17 cities. Is that right? Yeah.
直接去洛杉矶吗？嗯，让我想想。嗯，我其实是一个军队，准确地说是空军家庭的孩子，所以我们在各地都长住过。得了吧。我丈夫斯科蒂是个军队家庭的孩子。在大概17个城市长大。是吗？对。
Yeah, so he's been traveling around. So my dad was in the Air Force, and so in the 70s, we were in Germany. And then we came back to Nashville. I grew up there, and then I started making movies when I was 14. Well, how old were you when you left Germany, and were you old enough to know German? Yes, I was five. I spoke German then. What part of Germany?
对，所以他一直在到处搬。所以我爸爸在空军，所以在70年代，我们在德国。然后我们回到纳什维尔。我在那儿长大，然后我14岁开始拍电影。嗯，你离开德国时多大，你到了懂德语的年龄了吗？是的，我那时五岁。我当时会说德语。德国哪个地方？
I lived in Wiesbaden on an Army base. Scotty lived in Stuttgart. Oh, really? Yeah. Those are neighbor cities because I think Wiesbaden is where the Porsche test track is, from what I understand. Oh, that might be right. That's true.
我住在威斯巴登的一个陆军基地。斯科蒂住在斯图加特。哦，真的吗？对。那是邻近的城市，因为据我所知，保时捷的测试跑道就在威斯巴登。哦，那可能是对的。没错。
That's true. We went to, one time we were going over to Europe, and Dax was going over with us like the day before, and he lands in Frankfurt, and he says to the guy, he rented a Porsche from like Avis or whatever, and he goes, can I, can you tell me how to get to that test track, and the guy goes, yeah, of course you go this way, but you must not use this car on the test, and the guy goes, oh no, for sure, for sure I won't, no, for sure I won't, but just tell me where it is, and the guy's like, okay, it is here, but let me be clear, you cannot use this on the, of course, of course I won't, yeah, for sure, thanks man,
没错。我们去，有一次我们要去欧洲，戴克斯就像前一天一样跟我们一起去，他在法兰克福降落，他对那个人说，他从Avis还是什么地方租了一辆保时捷，他说，我能，你能告诉我怎么去那个测试跑道吗，那个人说，可以啊，当然你可以走这条路，但你绝对不能在测试中使用这辆车，然后那个人说，哦不，当然不会，我绝对不会，不，我绝对不会，但只要告诉我它在哪就行，然后那个人就说，好吧，它在这儿，但我得说清楚，你绝对不能在上面，当然，当然我不会，对，肯定的，谢了兄弟，
you know, great to the test track. Is that your German accent? It's pretty good. Oh, it's not. If I close my eyes, I'm in Berlin. Wow, crazy. How would you like it to sound, Mr. Hayes? Oh, this is better.
你知道的，直奔测试跑道。那是你的德国口音吗？挺不错的。哦，并不是。如果我闭上眼睛，我就在柏林了。哇，太疯狂了。海斯先生，你希望它听起来怎么样？哦，这个更好。
That is really good. That sounds threatening. That one I had to lean, but I was trying to oscillate back and forth between Mr. Schrappert and this guy, but Mr. Hayes, you have caught my attention now. Reese, Will wanted me to say this joke to you, which I just think is so dumb, but he wanted me to ask you, because everybody's been wondering. Wait, I thought, who knew that I was coming, and who didn't know that? That's why this is a joke.
那个真的很好。听起来很有威胁性。那个我得靠一下，但我一直在尝试在施拉珀特先生和这家伙之间来回摇摆，不过海斯先生，你现在引起我的注意了。瑞茜，威尔想让我对你讲这个笑话，我觉得这真是蠢透了，但他想让我问你，因为大家一直在纳闷。等等，我以为，谁知道我要来，谁不知道？这就是为什么这是一个笑话。
We know that this isn't real. If I had ever ran into you, Will wanted me to ask, have you ever been without your spoon? I would, but I'd be in pieces. So now, Reese, are you not sorry? Sorry, that's a crossover. You're talking to the voice of Reese's pieces right there. I am the voice of Reese's peanut butter cups. No, you aren't.
我们知道这不是真的。如果我曾经遇到过你，威尔想让我问，你有没有过没有勺子的经历？我会的，但我会粉身碎骨。所以现在，瑞茜，你难道不感到遗憾吗？抱歉，这是一个双关语。你刚才在跟瑞茜花生酱杯（Reese's Pieces）的配音员说话。我就是瑞茜花生酱杯的配音员。不，你不是。
Yeah, he really is. Reese Witherspoon, welcome to our show. Thanks, Sean. Welcome to the show. This is the show where Reese listens to three guys talk. I know. I know. I know.
对，他真的是。瑞茜·威瑟斯彭，欢迎来到我们的节目。谢谢，肖恩。欢迎来到节目。这就是那个让瑞茜听三个男人说话的节目。我知道。我知道。我知道。
Yeah. Sorry. Yeah. Welcome to Hollywood, people. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. You're like a huge, you were like the huge Avon or something, right?
对。抱歉。对。欢迎来到好莱坞，各位。对。对。对。你就像是个超级，你曾经就像是雅芳的代言人什么的，对吧？
I did Avon for years, and I did Elizabeth Arden for years. Do you have a commercial campaign you're excited about right now, Reese? Now, I have this great thing with Buick, where you, I have a book club called Reese's Book Club. Yes. Yeah. Sure. And in all the new Buicks, we have an app that plays all the Audible books and all my
我给雅芳代言了好多年，我也给伊丽莎白·雅顿代言了好多年。瑞茜，你现在有什么让你兴奋的商业活动吗？现在，我和别克有一个很棒的合作，你，我有一个读书俱乐部叫“瑞茜读书俱乐部”。对。没错。当然。而且在所有新款别克汽车里，我们都有一个应用程序，里面播放所有的有声书和我所有
favorite podcasts. Oh, wow. Which is kind of fun. Great idea. I thought you were going to say, in every Buick, there's a stand to put a book that you read at stoplights. Oh, God, Sean. So wait a minute.
最喜欢的播客。哦，哇。这挺有意思的。好主意。我还以为你要说的是，在每一辆别克里，都有一个架子，可以放你在红灯时阅读的书。哦，天哪，肖恩。所以等等。
Audio books are in the Buicks? Yeah, they're in that. All of our picks are embedded in the Buick. And I'm, I got so excited, y'all. I saw it for the first time. And I was like, you know what, I'm going to strike you to what I thought my name was on Jeopardy. That's how excited.
有声书在别克汽车里？对，就在那个里面。我们所有的精选书目都内置在别克里。而且我，我太兴奋了，各位。我第一次看到它的时候。我就想，你知道吗，我要把它震撼到像我认为我在《危险边缘》里的名字一样。兴奋到这种程度。
Oh, my. And my name has been on Jeopardy. But it was above. Yeah. I just threw that down. What was it? Was it a Jeopardy thing going on? Yeah.
哦，天哪。而且我的名字确实上过《危险边缘》。但那是在上面。Yeah.我直接把这个抛出来了。那是什么？那是《危险边缘》的一个题目吗？对。
Sure. Yeah. Was it a $1,200 or $200? I think I was a 500 first round clue. Oh. Oh, there was a girl, this sweet girl once sweaped because I was a whole category. Are you serious? But it's actually worth Googling because the two dudes next to her had no idea who I was.
当然。对。那是1200美元还是200美元的题？我觉得我是第一轮500美元的线索。哦。哦，曾有一个女孩，这个甜美的女孩曾经大获全胜，因为我成了一个完整的类别。你是认真的吗？但真的很值得去谷歌一下，因为她身边的两个大老爷们根本不知道我是谁。
And she's like, likely blonde, Tracy Flick. Do you remember the title of the category? It was something like Reese's Pieces. Yeah, of course. Of course. Of course. If only you had read it well. I know.
而她就像是，金发碧眼，特雷西·弗里克。你还记得那个类别的名字吗？大概是“瑞茜的花生酱杯”之类的。对，当然。当然。当然。要是你当时读好了就好了。我知道。
I wish. I wish. I want to know like a crazy audition story. Like, because we've all shared ours. A crazy audition or a crazy job. What about one that you wish you would have gotten that somebody else got? They did a great job and you? Oh, well, I really wanted Clueless when I was 18.
我希望。我希望。我想知道一个疯狂的试镜故事。比如，因为我们都分享过我们的。一个疯狂的试镜或一份疯狂的工作。有没有哪个角色你希望自己拿到却被别人拿了？他们做得很好，而你？哦，嗯，我18岁的时候真的很想演《独领风骚》。
Great. Like, I've never told anybody and then Amy Heckerling did a whole thing in Vanity Fair last year and told everybody. Oh, wow. You know what? That shit pops up and you're like, thanks. Yeah. I never really let anybody know how hard I went at that one and didn't get it.
太棒了。就像，我从来没告诉过任何人，然后去年艾米·海克林在《名利场》上做了一个专题，把所有人都抖出来了。哦，哇。你知道吗？那破事突然冒出来，然后你就想，谢谢啦。对。我从来没让任何人知道我为那个角色付出了多少努力却没拿到。
I went pretty hard. Are you a fan of the writing an email to the director or the producer or, you know, sort of declaring how you are for something or do you think it's better strategy to kind of have sexy indifference? No, I'm the passionate go for it person because I feel like ego is the death of creativity. Yes. If your ego comes before it, you can't be on set in a collaborative medium like this. We work with 200, 300 people a day.
我当时真的很拼。你是一个喜欢给导演或制片人写电子邮件，或者，你知道的，宣示你有多适合某个角色的人呢，还是觉得保持性感冷漠才是更好的策略？不，我是那种充满激情、全力以赴的人，因为我觉得自我（Ego）是创造力的死敌。是的。如果你的自我凌驾于一切之上，你就无法在这个像这样的合作媒介中留在片场。我们每天要和200、300人一起工作。
If you can't bend your ego to the side for a minute, you're not going to do very well. I totally agree. Art is absent of ego, I think. It should be, but I mean, y'all did just talk about each other for like 10 solid minutes now. I'm just kidding. Well, we love each other a lot. But wait, so I'm really psyched about this thing you did with Buick about putting these
如果你不能把自我暂时收敛一下，你在这行就混不好。我完全同意。我认为艺术是没有自我的。本来就该如此，不过我是说，你们刚才不也连续聊了整整10分钟彼此吗？我开玩笑的。好吧，我们非常喜欢彼此。不过等等，所以我对你跟别克合作把这些
books. Oh my God, please listen to us. Well, I just want to say, so you have this book club and this was like the natural progression of that. I mean, obviously, right? So how did you start the book club thing? What was the genesis of that? Well, you know, I started this book club because first, before I started the book club, I started
书放进去的事感到超级兴奋。哦，天哪，请听我们说。好吧，我只是想说，所以你有这个读书俱乐部，这是这自然而然的发展。我的意思是，很明显，对吧？所以你是怎么开始这个读书俱乐部的？它的起源是什么？嗯，你知道的，我之所以创办这个读书俱乐部，是因为首先，在我创办读书俱乐部之前，我大概在10年前创办
a production company probably 10 years ago because all the scripts I was getting were just so god-awful, like literally awful. And listener, this is the gold standard of all production companies in Hollywood, by the way. Thanks for saying that. This witherspoon here is now, and it also dovetails into your book club thing because, listener, she reads, I think, correct me if I'm wrong, a book a day. Do you really read a book a day?
了一家制作公司，因为我当时收到的剧本简直太糟糕了，字面意义上的糟糕。而且听众们，顺便说一句，这是好莱坞所有制作公司的黄金标准。谢谢你这么说。这里的这位威瑟斯彭现在，而且这也完美契合了你的读书俱乐部，因为，听众们，如果我没记错的话，她大概一天读一本书。你真的每天读一本书吗？
Probably every two days. She's insane. Are you kidding me? No. I'm so jealous. My eyes get crossed sometimes. That's why I wear glasses a lot. What about scripts?
大概每两天一本吧。她疯了。你在开玩笑吧？没有。我太嫉妒了。我的眼睛有时候都会对眼。这就是为什么我经常戴眼镜。剧本呢？
Does that mean that you'd rather read a book than a script or you...? I read scripts, but there aren't as many scripts because I'm very discerning about what books we develop. So the book club came out of the first two books I optioned for my production company were Gone Girl and Wild, and they were both hit number one at the same time. And somebody said to me, well, you keep putting all this stuff on your Instagram. Why don't you just make a separate Instagram about the books you read? And so I did, and it just started doing really well.
这是否意味着你宁愿读一本书而不是剧本，还是说你……我读剧本，但剧本没有那么多，因为我对我们开发的图书非常有挑剔的眼光。所以读书俱乐部的诞生是因为我为我的制作公司买下的前两个版权是《消失的爱人》和《走出荒野》，它们当时同时登上了畅销榜第一名。有人对我说，你看，你把所有这些东西都发在你的Instagram上。你为什么不专门开一个Instagram来发你读的书呢？于是我就照做了，结果它真的做得很火。
And it actually has been this incredible opportunity to have first-time authors get their book noticed and seen. Yeah, that's exciting. And now are these publishers giving you early looks at things and hoping that you'll like it and that you... Yeah. So I'm reading right now for February. Right, of course.
而且它确实成为了一个不可思议的契机，让那些新锐作家的书能够被注意到和看到。对，这太令人兴奋了。现在这些出版商会提前把东西给你看，希望你会喜欢并且你……对。所以我现在正在读二月份的书。对，当然。
Wow. Now, do you have people that you trust? You've got to have people that help you with some of the reading. There's like me and one other person, I read it, my CEO of my company are doing it together. And so you're wading through all of it yourself, like, that's amazing, that's a lot of work. Yeah, but you can get through, well, the first filter is it's written by a woman and it has a woman at the center of it. And I have a no women locked in a basement rule.
哇。现在，你有你信任的人吗？你肯定得有人帮你读一些书。就是我和另外一个人，我读，我公司的首席执行官，我们一起做这件事。所以你得自己涉猎所有这些内容，天哪，这工作量太大了。对，不过你能看完，好吧，第一个筛选标准是它必须由女性撰写，并且以女性为中心。而且我有一条“绝不把女人锁在地下室”的规则。
Why? Why? Oh God, why is that? That actually reminds me of the story. I was like, I have two big little eyes, this executive in LA called me in, one of the major studios and he was like, hey, hey, I just, we would love to have something like Big Little Lies at our studio and I'm like, oh, thank you so much. He was like, it was so good, I just have, I just have one, one little comment.
为什么？为什么？哦，天哪，为什么是这样？这其实让我想起了一个故事。当时我，我有两部《大小谎言》，洛杉矶的一位高管把我叫去，是某个大制片厂的，他对我说，嘿，嘿，我只是，我们很希望在我们的制片厂里有像《大小谎言》这样的作品，然后我说，哦，非常感谢。他说，这太棒了，我只是有，我只是有一个，一个小小的意见。
I can't believe it's coming. I can't believe it's coming. The guy's parts just, they're just not as good. Yeah. Wow. That is genius. Wow. So you're getting it.
我简直不敢相信它要来了。我简直不敢相信它要来了。那里的男性角色，就是，就是没那么好。Yeah.哇。这太天才了。哇。所以你明白了。
Wow. And who was that, not the name, but that, that was somebody at a, at a, a buyer? He ran a major studio. He's just emailed me yesterday and he's like, out of the business now, starting an app. And he's like, hey, I'm starting an app. Wow. For men. Do you have any guy-centric ideas for my app?
哇。那是谁，不用说名字，但那是，那是某个买家的人吗？他经营着一家大制片厂。他昨天刚给我发电子邮件，说他现在离开这个行业了，正在开发一个应用程序。他说，嘿，我要开发一个应用程序。哇。针对男性的。你有什么以男性为中心的想法可以给我的应用吗？
Exactly. He had all the guys starting the app too. Oh my God. It's amazing. I'm fascinated in the reading of it all. So are you a, are you a speed reader or are you just great? Yeah. I can read really fast.
没错。他的应用也是一帮男的在搞。哦，天哪。这太神奇了。我对这种阅读过程本身很着迷。所以你是一个，你是一个速读高手，还是说你只是天赋异禀？对。我能读得非常快。
And that is just something that came naturally to you or is that, or did you work on that when you were a kid? I actually didn't know that was like something that everybody didn't have until I met my husband and we were probably going on a date or something. One weekend he was like, hey, can we go out of town? I was like, yeah, I just have to read scripts. He's like, you're going to be reading a, I was like, yeah, I just have three scripts to read.
那是你天生就会的，还是说，或者你在小时候练习过？我其实不知道这是不是那种不是每个人都有的技能，直到我遇到了我丈夫，当时我们可能正在约会什么的。有个周末他说，嘿，我们能离开外地吗？我说，行，我只是得读剧本。他说，你还要读一个，我说，对，我只有三个剧本要读。
That's going to take all weekend. And I was like, oh no, no, no, no, are you kidding? And he's like, you can, I was like, it takes me about 45 minutes to read script. And then, you know, I'm just going to, and he was like, what? And so I didn't know. I think my grandma was a first grade teacher and she taught me how to read when I was four or five. And I think she taught me how to speed read.
那要花一整个周末呢。然后我说，哦不不不不，你在开玩笑吧？然后他说，你可以，我说，我读一个剧本大概只需要45分钟。然后，你知道的，我这就去，然后他说，什么？所以我当时并不知道。我想我奶奶是一年级老师，她在我四五岁的时候教我认字。我想她教过我如何速读。
Wow. But I, I can't ask her because she's not here anymore. God bless you grandma. But I do read really fast. It took Jason, it took Jason three days to read the definition of reading, and it's only a paragraph. I couldn't figure out the left to right. I had the top to bottom thing.
哇。但我不能问她了，因为她已经不在了。上帝保佑你，奶奶。但我确实读得非常快。杰森花了两天才把“阅读”的定义读完，而且那才只有一个段落。我搞不懂从左到右。我只有从上到下的概念。
Top to bottom. Yeah. So do you, do you, do you know if you have a specific technique, like some people say like they group three words at a time or, but you know what is so fascinating? Have you ever taken time on set to see how your fellow actor memorizes lines? I'm fascinated because I can tell, no, because I, it's, it's such a solitary. Right. So we all probably memorize our lines in different ways.
从上到下。对。那你，那你，你知道你有没有什么具体的技巧，比如有些人说他们一次看三个词，不过你知道最让人着迷的是什么吗？你在片场有没有花时间观察过你的同行演员是怎么背台词的？我很着迷，因为我看得出来，没有，因为我，这太孤独了。对。所以我们大家背台词的方法可能都不一样。
And so if you start to ask people what their tricks are, it, that it has a lot to do with how you read. Do you ever do this? Whenever you memorize lines, whenever you memorize lines, do you remember, like if you forget a word, but you remember the letter it starts with? Yes. That happens to me a lot. Yes.
所以如果你开始问别人的秘诀是什么，它其实和你的阅读方式有很大关系。你有没有过这种经历？每当你背台词的时候，每当你背台词的时候，你还记得，比如如果你忘了一个词，但你还记得它以什么字母开头吗？是的。我经常遇到这种情况。是的。
What about y'all? I can see the page. You can see the whole page. All I have to do is see it basically once. Jason's the fastest I've ever worked with in terms of memorizing. He and I are both pretty quick at the same time. I remember one time Jason and I were going to do a scene on Arrested when we were doing that Netflix season and we walked, there was a two man scene and it was like eight pages.
你们呢？我能看到那一页。你能看到整页纸。我基本上只需要看一眼就行了。杰森是我合作过的背台词速度最快的人。我和他都属于反应相当快的那种。我记得有一次杰森和我准备在《发展受阻》里拍一场戏，那是我们拍网飞那一季的时候，我们走过去，那是一场两个人的戏，大概有八页纸。
And right as we were walking to set, Mitch Roberts goes, Hey guys, we just rewrote it. And it was one of the first scenes and we both were walking and Jason would go, blah, blah, blah. Then you're going to say blah, blah, blah, blah. We looked, we looked, we looked, we looked, we buried the script and we started shooting. Did you remember that, Jay? Yeah. That's so amazing.
就在我们走向片场的时候，米奇·罗伯茨说，嘿，伙计们，我们刚刚重写了。那是第一场戏中的一场，我们俩一边走，杰森就一边说，吧啦吧啦吧啦。然后你要说，吧啦吧啦吧啦。我们看了一眼，看了一眼，看了一眼，看了一眼，我们合上剧本就开始拍了。你还记得吗，杰、？对。这太神奇了。
Also, Mitch Roberts writes such good dialogue. Good dialogue. It is. If it's well written, it does go into your brain pretty easily. When it's well written. But so Reese, when you memorize though, are you, you're going top to bottom on the page and you're just memorizing it like that or are you memorizing it in groups or thoughts? Do you memorize it as fast as you read?
而且，米奇·罗伯茨写的对话太棒了。好对话。确实如此。如果写得好，它确实能很轻松地进入你的大脑。当它写得很好的时候。不过瑞茜，当你背台词的时候，你是，你是从上到下一页一页地读，然后就这样把它背下来，还是说你把它们分成组或按思想去背？你背台词的速度有你阅读那么快吗？
I don't know. It takes me three runs. I have to read it the night before, then during hair and makeup, then I have to say it alone in a quiet space. And then I have to hold the sides, even though the sides have nothing to do. Sides are our little lines that we carry on set. And then for the rehearsal, I have to hold them in my hand. And then during the blocking, wherever I stand is where I say the line.
我不知道。我得经历三遍。我必须在前一天晚上读一遍，然后在做发型和化妆的时候读，然后我得在一个安静的空间里独自把它念出来。然后我必须拿着台词页（sides），尽管台词页跟这完全没关系。台词页就是我们在片场随身携带的小剧本。然后排练的时候，我必须把它拿在手里。然后在走位（blocking）的时候，我站在哪里就在哪里说这句台词。
And if you change my blocking, I can't remember the line. Right. Forget it. Yeah. I can't remember my lines until the scene is blocked. Same. Wait, I want to hear your process, Jason, because this kind of stuff is really fascinating to me.
如果你改变我的走位，我就记不住台词了。对。拉倒吧。对。在场景走位完成之前，我是记不住台词的。一样。等等，我想听听你的流程，杰森，因为这种事情对我来说真的太迷人了。
Blocking is what, Jason? Is where you stand, where you sit, when you get up, all that stuff. This is, this is for Sean's aunt in Wisconsin, I believe it is. No. No, Sean was very happy. You see how excited Sean got when recently he was very kindly explained what sides are. Right. And Sean was so excited because he loves explaining things.
走位是什么，杰森？就是你站在哪儿，坐在哪儿，你什么时候站起来，诸如此类的事情。这是，这是为肖恩在威斯康星州的姑妈准备的，我想是的。不。不，肖恩非常高兴。你看肖恩刚才多兴奋，当瑞茜很体贴地解释了什么是台词页的时候。对。而且肖恩超级兴奋，因为他最喜欢解释事情了。
Well, I think that's important. I do too. Thank you, Reese Witherspoon. That's her name, by the way. What's the sister's name? Tracy. So it's the Tracy ticker, bottom of the screen for the explanation. Okay.
嗯，我觉得这很重要。我也这么觉得。谢谢你，瑞茜·威瑟斯彭。顺便说一句，这才是她的名字。那个姐姐叫什么名字？特雷西。所以屏幕底部有解释说明的“特雷西滚动字幕”（Tracy ticker）。好吧。
So what I do is I, I think a lot about, about, about how I'm going to do it, which is, which is actually not really a good thing to do as an actor. And that's why I don't really get them perfectly memorized before I do it because I don't want to nail in how I'm going to do it because I got to leave room for how you're going to be doing your lines, you know, so I can be flexible with performance. So actually I learned my lines specifically once we do our rehearsal. And then they're lighting the shot and the stand-ins are in there. Have you ever had this moment on set where you're looking at somebody and they're doing,
所以我的做法是，我，我花很多时间去思考，去思考，思考我该怎么演，而这，其实作为演员来说并不是一件很好的事。这就是为什么我在演之前并没有把它们背得十全十美，因为我不想把我的演法给钉死，我得给你的表演留出空间，你知道的，这样我才能在表演中保持灵活性。所以实际上，我通常是在我们排练过一次之后才专门去记台词的。然后他们正在给镜头打光，替身演员在里面。你在片场有没有过这种时刻，你看着某个人，他们正在，
like they're doing such incredible work, you forget the lines? Yeah. All the time. You start watching. I do that a lot when I'm directing. Yeah. You get out of your body and you start looking at them and going like, either, holy shit, they're so bad in this scene or, oh my God, I can't believe I get to act with this human.
就像他们正在做如此不可思议的表演，以至于你把台词都忘了？对。随时都在忘。你看着看着就入迷了。我当导演的时候经常这样。对。你跳出了自己的身体，开始看着他们然后心想，要么，卧槽，他们这场戏演得太烂了，要么，天哪，我简直不敢相信我能跟这个人同台演戏。
When I'm directing something that I'm in, I've got to be doing that. Like I've got to be watching their performance at the same time. So yes, sometimes it is, and you're thinking about, oh my God, how am I going to edit around this performance? Jason, that's got to be so hard. But it's fun because it's a great, it's a perfect seat to have, like you're right there and you can actually, if they're open to it, you can give them adjustments and notes while you're inside the scene.
当我执导自己参演的戏时，我必须得这么做。就好像我必须同时在观看他们的表演。所以是的，有时候确实是这样，你在想，天哪，我该怎么把这场戏剪辑好呢。杰森，那一定很难吧。但这也很有趣，因为这是一个绝佳的位置，你就在那儿，而且如果他们愿意的话，你甚至可以在场景里面直接给他们调整和笔记。
You don't necessarily have to wait till the end and try to remember your notes and stuff like that. That's cool. But I love it. I can't memorize lines without making a choice. I know a lot of actors, like you just said, Jason, they memorize the words, but they wait until rehearsal to kind of figure out how it goes. Memorize it like a robot.
你不需要非得等到最后才去绞尽脑汁回想你的笔记之类的事情。这很酷。但我很喜欢。我不做选择就根本背不出台词。我知道很多演员，就像你刚才说的，杰森，他们只是死记硬背单词，但他们要等到排练时才去琢磨该怎么演。像机器人一样背。
Some will even write it down. They'll write their lines out and they'll remember every single word, like real staccato. I couldn't do that. I worked with this actor once and he couldn't, if you ad-libbed it all, and it was comedy. So you got to just be loose, you know, because that stuff gets really stuck and not funny. It gets not funny after take three. It's just not funny anymore. And if I didn't say the last written line, he literally only knew my last word.
有些人甚至会把它写下来。他们会把台词写出来，然后记住每一个字，就像机关枪一样字顿句绝。我做不到。我以前跟一个演员合作过，他完全不行，如果你稍微即兴发挥一下，而且那是喜剧。所以你必须得放松，你知道的，因为那些东西一旦死板了就一点也不好笑了。拍到第三条的时候就彻底不好笑了。如果我没说最后那句写好的台词，他字面意义上只记得我的最后一个词。
So if I didn't say the word, he would remember his line. I thought, he's not listening to me. Am I wrong? Yeah. I've worked with people like that who are like, oh, sorry, I didn't hear the cue. And you're like, well, how did you not know that I was saying the same thing? Raise the intention. Yeah, it's the intention.
所以如果我没说那个词，他就想不起自己的台词了。我心想，他根本没在听我说话。我错了吗？对。我跟那种人合作过，他们会说，哦，抱歉，我没听到 cue 点。然后你就会想，那你怎么会不知道我刚才在说同一件事呢？加大潜台词（intention）。对，就是潜台词。
Yeah, stupid ass. I usually just wait for a huge gaping pause, and that's when I know I come out. They stop talking. It's my turn. I spent half my time so excited about doing something that's going to crack the other person up. So I'm just giddy. I'm like bursting this to fuck around at all times, even in life, that I'm just like
对，大笨蛋。我通常只是等着一个巨大的空白停顿，然后我就知道该我上场了。他们不说话了。轮到我了。我有一半的时间都沉浸在做一件能把对方逗得哈哈大笑的事情中的兴奋感里。所以我整个人晕乎乎的。我简直随时随地都想胡闹，甚至在生活中也是如此，所以我就是
giddy. That's so fun to be around. People who are like so excited to ad-lib, and it's so fun. Yeah, I love that. It's infectious. Yeah. You guys seem to be having that kind of vibe on Morning Show. We don't ad-lib that much on Morning Show, but we have such great dialogue.
晕乎乎的。跟这种人在一起太有趣了。那些热衷于即兴发挥的人，真的太好玩了。对，我喜欢这样。这很有感染力。对。你们在《早间新闻》剧组好像也是这种氛围。我们在《早间新闻》里不怎么即兴发挥，但我们的台词真的太棒了。
Yeah. Yeah, it's so good. By the way, I love the show, and you're fantastic. Thank you. So good in it. So, so, so good. I love it. I really love it.
对。对，真的太棒了。顺便说一句，我超爱这部剧，你演得太棒了。谢谢。在里面太棒了。太棒太棒了。我爱死它了。我真的超爱。
It's so fun. It's great to work with Jen every day, and all those incredible people, and even like Martin Schwart came on our show, and I was freaking out. I know. He was so great. I think he got nominated, didn't he? He did. He did.
太有趣了。每天能和詹（詹妮弗·安妮斯顿）以及所有这些不可思议的人一起工作感觉太棒了，甚至像马丁·肖特来客串我们的节目时，我都快吓疯了。我知道。他太棒了。我记得他被提名了吧？他被提名了。他确实被提名了。
Yeah, he did. He did. When do you guys go back? We're going to go back right now. It's going to be interesting. I've been talking to some friends who are on sets and wearing masks, and then I'm like, what's it like to try and stay in the scene, but then also stay safe and keep everybody safe?
对，他提名了。你们什么时候复工？我们马上就要复工了。这将会很有趣。我一直在和一些在片场戴着口罩的朋友聊天，然后我就在想，一边努力保持入戏，一边又要确保安全、保护每个人，这会是一种什么体验？
So, just kind of trying to mentally prepare for that, but I'm excited to work again because I'm going nuts over here. You and me both. Look at us. We started a God Deal podcast. We're so crazy. You guys are so much fun to listen to. I was like, hold on.
所以，就是在精神上做一下这种准备，但我很高兴能再次工作，因为我在这里快要疯了。你我都一样。看看我们。我们开了一个上帝知道什么名字的播客。我们太疯狂了。你们这节目听起来太有意思了。我当时想，等等。
I called Mindy Kaling. I was like, should we be doing what those guys are doing? Yeah, you should. Yeah. You should. Yeah. Get on it. Well, your list of accomplishments is endless, speaking of like, I don't know what to do
我给明迪·卡灵打电话说，我们是不是也该做那些家伙在做的事？对，你们应该做。对。你们应该做。赶紧的。好吧，说到不知道该拿自己怎么办，你的成就简直无休无止，因为我也差不多，但你比我高产得多。你的演艺生涯、制片生涯、服装公司、读书俱乐部，你现在同时出现在大概七个电视节目里。哦，哦，你还是个妈妈。我的意思是，这些家伙知道我的故事，但你小时候到底发生了什么鬼，才让你有了这种无止境的雄心？
with myself because I'm similar, but you're much more prolific than I am. Your acting career, your producing career, your clothing company, your book club, you're like in seven television shows right now all at once. Oh, and oh, you're a mom. I mean, these guys know my story, but what in the hell happened to you as a child that gave you this like boundless ambition? Well, I was always like a really overachieving kid, but I wanted, you know, I think every actor has to kind of dig down and figure out who are you trying to make happy.
嗯，我从小就是一个好胜心极强的小孩，但我想要，你知道的，我觉得每个演员都必须深入挖掘，弄清楚你到底想取悦谁。
So once you figure that out, like I figured that out through seven years of therapy. I figured it out. Yeah. Oh, you graduated. Well, I think I graduated from therapy. My therapist passed away. So I didn't go anywhere. Oh, no.
所以一旦你弄清楚了这一点，就像我通过七年的治疗弄清楚了一样。我搞明白了。对哦，你毕业了。嗯，我想我是从心理治疗中毕业了。我的治疗师去世了。所以我没去别的地方。哦，不。
But then when she figured it out. Was it a parent? Was it a family member? Yes. For sure, for sure. It's always right. Am I right? Am I wrong?
但后来当她想通了。是父母吗？是家庭成员吗？对。肯定的，肯定的。总是这样。我说的对吗？我说的错吗？
How do y'all feel? Give me an amen. For sure. I'm still trying to get my out of boys. Yeah. So it's usually like, who's approval are you trying to get? And once you kind of saw that puzzle, then it's like, okay, why am I still doing this? What am I doing?
大家感觉怎么样？给我个“阿门”。肯定的。我还在试图从别人那里得到肯定呢（out of boys）。对。所以通常是，你想得到谁的认可？一旦你理清了这个谜题，然后就会觉得，好吧，我为什么还要这么做？我在干什么？
That's when my whole career shifted to more purpose driven. I want more women behind the camera. I want to see more stories written from a woman's perspective by a woman. I want us to have women make more money. And it just gave me fuel. You know? Yeah. It's changed my whole life.
就在那时，我的整个职业生涯转向了更有目标驱动的方向。我想要镜头后面有更多的女性。我想看到更多从女性视角出发、由女性撰写的故事。我希望我们能让女性赚更多的钱。这给了我动力。你知道吗？对。这改变了我的一生。
Is that what inspired you to, in the lead, in the way of fight for women's equality and equal pay for genders? And do you think your efforts have paid off? And where are we? Absolutely. I mean, I see so much shifting, so much more consciousness. The lights are on. People are actually having these conversations and discussions.
这就是启发你带头为人权平等和性别同工同酬而战的原因吗？你觉得你们的努力有回报吗？我们现在进展到哪一步了？当然。我的意思是，我看到了如此多的转变，意识提高了很多。灯亮了。人们真的在进行这些对话和讨论。
Yeah. And you all know how prolific it was that there were no people of color at agencies and no people of color as executives at studios. And now I'm seeing so much more of an effort to actually diversify storytelling by changing the storytellers, but also the executives that make the decisions are just becoming more diverse, which is going to really create a better diversity of programming and the emergence of streaming has helped everyone because it opens it up. It just opens it up.
对。而且你们都知道，过去在经纪公司里没有有色人种，在制片厂高管里也没有有色人种，这种现象是多么普遍。而现在，我看到越来越多的努力，通过改变讲故事的人来使讲故事多元化，同时做出决策的高管们也变得更加多元化，这真的会创造出更好、更多元化的节目，而流媒体的出现帮助了每个人，因为它把格局打开了。它彻底打开了。
I remember being, you know, when I was first dating Amy, my ex-wife, and then when we were married and people would talk, you know, there was that whole thing that used to be like, you know, like, well, there was always that argument, like, women aren't as funny. And I was like, not as funny. The funniest people I know are women. Are women. I know. Tina and Amy.
我记得，你知道的，当我刚开始和我的前妻艾米交往时，后来当我们结婚后，人们会谈论，你知道，当时有那种普遍的说法，就像是，你知道的，嗯，总是有一种争论，比如，女性没有那么搞笑。而我当时想，没有那么搞笑？我认识最搞笑的人就是女性。就是女性。我知道。蒂娜和艾米。
Tina and Maya and Rachel Dratch. I'm like, are you for fucking real? They're the funniest people, period. And the fact that there was even a debate was so absurd, although it should be noted one time I did an interview and they said, what's it like being married to the funniest person in America? And I said, you'd have to ask my wife. You know, I think you guys got divorced three days later.
蒂娜、玛雅和雷切尔·德拉奇。我在想，你们是在他妈的开玩笑吧？她们就是最搞笑的人，句号。甚至还有过这种辩论，这本身就荒谬至极，尽管值得一提的是，有一次我接受采访，他们问我，和一个全美最搞笑的人结婚是什么感觉？我说，你得去问我妻子。你知道，我觉得你们大概三天后就离婚了吧。
Are you guys still married or are you excited about Kamala Harris? Oh, gosh. Y'all, your interview with her was so well timed. Oh, I know. It was crazy. How lucky was that? Was that crazy? Yeah, that's insane.
你们俩现在还在一起，还是说你对卡玛拉·哈里斯很兴奋？哦，天哪。各位，你们对她的采访时机把握得太好了。哦，我知道。太疯狂了。那有多幸运？这不是很疯狂吗？对，太疯狂了。
We were chasing it for a little while. And then the fact that she said, you know, she picked the date and we were like, she must know that she's picking a date the week that he's going to make his pick. She called us like the week before and was like, we got to go now. And at that point we were like, oh, this, this is happening. You all like. Yes, something's happening. She's awesome.
我们追了她好一会儿。然后事实上她说，你知道，她挑了一个日期，而我们在想，她一定知道她挑的这个日期正好是特朗普挑选副手的那周。她大概在前一周给我们打电话说，我们必须马上开始。当时我们就觉得，哦，这，这要发生了。你们就像是。是的，有事情要发生了。她太棒了。
You all raised to the microphones. It was so good. It was so good and it means so much, you know, that she just represents so much to women out there, little girls, little girls, black and brown girls all over this country now know that anything is possible. And it's so important, you know, that we'd be so lucky. We'd be so lucky to have her vice president and then hopefully president. She's incredible.
你们面对着麦克风高声呐喊。这太棒了。太棒了，而且意义重大，你知道的，她对女性、小女孩们，对全美各地的小女孩、黑人和棕色人种女孩来说，代表了太多的意义，她们现在知道一切皆有可能。这太重要了，你知道的，我们太幸运了。我们能有她当副总统，然后希望将来成为总统，这真是太幸运了。她太不可思议了。
Anybody who dedicates their life to public service like that is just really remarkable. And I'm also fascinated about her husband, Doug. I want to learn about Doug. Doug's amazing. I want to follow Doug for the next 12 years. I want to see what's going on with him. My husband's friends with Doug. He really likes Doug.
任何把一生奉献给这种公共服务的人都真的非常了不起。而且我也对她的丈夫道格很着迷。我想了解道格。道格太棒了。我想在接下来12年里都关注道格。我想看看他最近在忙什么。我丈夫和道格是朋友。他真的很喜欢道格。
Really? Oh, really? Yeah. We talked him for a minute at the start. Yeah, he was hilarious. He was so cool. He was setting up her computer. He's doing all the tech stuff, right?
真的吗？哦，真的吗？对。我们刚开始时跟他聊了一会儿。对，他太搞笑了。他太酷了。他在帮她设置电脑。他在做所有的技术活，对吧？
For the... He's the greatest guy. He was super funny. And they have great kids. Yeah. And we said, what's it like? He said, Jason said the vetting process just must be pretty intense and he just whispered to you guys.
为了……他真的是个最棒的家伙。他超级搞笑。而且他们有很棒的孩子。对。我们问，这感觉怎么样？他说，杰森说背景审查的过程一定相当紧张，然后他悄悄对你们说。
You have no idea. He looked straight into the camera. It was the only time he did it. Can you even imagine? Would y'all ever want to run for office? I know y'all asked that on the show, but I wonder. I mean... These guys said that I could never be the prime minister of Canada, which I took great
你们根本不知道。他直视着镜头。那是他唯一一次这么做。你们能想象吗？你们会想去竞选公职吗？我知道你们在节目里问过这个，但我很好奇。我是说……这些家伙说我永远不能当加拿大的总理，我对此感到非常冒犯。
umbrage with. Yeah, I think with your dual citizenship, you've kind of screwed yourself out of both. I'm screwed out of both. Yeah. Reese, what about you? Because you already act like... Yeah, Reese, I was going to say... You're president of so many companies.
对，我觉得凭你的双重国籍，你基本上把自己两条路都堵死了。我两边都堵死了。对。瑞茜，你呢？因为你本来就已经表现得……对，瑞茜，我正想说……你是那么多公司的总裁。
You know what I mean? You have that about you. You have that intelligence and charm and like ability and all of those things that are needed. And people look up to you and they listen to you because you are an influencer. Oh, thanks for saying that. That's true. Yeah, I think you'd get a lot of the vote. You'd be a senator like this.
你知道我的意思吗？你身上有那种特质。你拥有那种智慧、魅力和亲和力，以及所有必需的那些东西。人们仰慕你，听你的话，因为你是一个意见领袖。哦，谢谢你这么说。确实如此。对，我觉得你能得到很多选票。你轻而易举就能当上参议员。
Right? Yeah, I mean it. I mean it. You should do it. Yeah, I mean our standards have become very low in this country. Sunny Bono was one of our congressmen. Yeah, wait a second, we don't have to say that the bar is low for Reese to do it. No, I mean I'm just saying it's like, you know, come on, like...
对吧？对，我是认真的。我是认真的。你应该去试试。对，我是说，我们在国内的标准已经变得很低了。索尼·波诺（Sonny Bono）曾是我们的一位国会议员。对，等一下，我们可不用说瑞茜去当的话门槛就很低。不，我的意思是，这就像是，拜托，就像……
Yeah, you'd be great. If you ever get bored of killing it in this industry. I love what we do. I feel so lucky to do with this. I feel like... So you wouldn't... You would never want to do that? I mean I wouldn't say never because I don't know where I'm going to be when I'm, you know, 65.
对，你会是个很棒的政治家。如果你有一天对在这个行业里大杀四方感到厌倦的话。我热爱我们所做的事。做这个让我觉得自己太幸运了。我觉得……所以你不会……你永远都不会想去那样做？我是说我不会把话说死，因为我不知道我到了65岁的时候会在哪里。
The thing that's seductive about the whole notion of running for politics for anybody, I'm sure, is you look at some of these problems and you just think the answer is so simple. Well, I think we need a better representation and balance too. I mean, women are 50% of the population, but we're not 50% of the representation in government, which is bizarre, particularly when they're adjudicating over our bodies. Yeah. And the lack of representation of people of color who make up a large, almost majority of this country. It's true.
对于任何人来说，参与政治竞选整个概念的诱惑之处在于，我确信，当你看着其中一些问题时，你会觉得答案是如此简单。嗯，我认为我们也需要更好的代表性和平衡。我的意思是，女性占人口的50%，但我们在政府中却没有50%的代表权，这太奇怪了，特别是当他们在对我们的身体进行裁决时。是的。而且有色人种缺乏代表性，他们构成了这个国家很大的一部分，几乎占了大多数。确实如此。
What about balance? You know, just yin and yang. Male, female, balance. I love all the countries that have handled COVID well or all run by women. Run by women, yeah. So like, you know, they're full stop. That's all you need to say. Well, I think women have a different relationship to power.
那平衡呢？你知道，就是阴和阳。男性，女性，平衡。我喜欢所有那些将新冠疫情处理得很好的国家，或者都是由女性领导的。由女性领导，是的。所以，就像，你知道，它们，句号。这就是你需要说的全部。嗯，我认为女性与权力的关系不同。
I mean... Oh, that's interesting. Yeah, yeah. Ooh, that's interesting. My company has, you know... It's all women, right? No, there's men there too. Oh, yeah.
我的意思是……哦，这很有趣。是的，是的。噢，这很有趣。我的公司有，你知道……全部都是女性，对吧？不，里面也有男性。哦，是的。
Yeah. And... Get them out of there. Come join us. But it's interesting how no one needs to be the number one. We sort of pass a baton almost. You know, it's always kind of deferring power or sharing responsibility. So it's almost this power balance and that there's no one person sort of dictating or
是的。还有……把他们弄出去。来加入我们吧。但有趣的是，没有人需要成为第一。我们有点像在传递接力棒。你知道，这总是某种程度上在推让权力或分担责任。所以这几乎是一种权力平衡，没有人独自在某种程度上发号施令或
mandating exactly what's going to happen. It's like collective ideas. And it works really well for... We're actually... Someone's doing a case study at it at one of the big business schools. What about the... About the... About our company, Hello Sunshine?
强制规定将要发生的事情。这就像集体的想法。而且它运作得非常好……我们实际上……有人在其中一所顶尖商学院做关于它的案例研究。关于……关于……关于我们的公司，Hello Sunshine？
Oh, gotcha. Hello Sunshine, yeah. You know, so we've got to change the way... And what you're talking about is changing the way... Changing our perspective on how we look at things and how... Well, yeah. And just listen. Yeah.
哦，明白了。Hello Sunshine，是的。你知道，所以我们必须改变方式……而你所谈论的是改变方式……改变我们看待事物的方式以及如何……嗯，是的。还有，倾听。是的。
Just listen. Yeah, Sean. Jesus. What? What did you say? Rhys, how are you managing your kids during this pandemic? Are you pulling your hair out, trying to keep them from having play dates with a family that might not be as isolated as you got?
只需倾听。是的，肖恩。天哪。什么？你说了什么？里斯，在这场大流行期间你是如何照顾你的孩子的？你是不是急得焦头烂额，试图阻止他们跟那些可能不像你隔离得那么好的家庭一起玩？
I mean, I'm asking because I'm dealing with it myself. I know. You're a great moron. I love your sweet girls. But your decisions as a parent are probably better than mine. So I want to know what you're doing. I don't know about that. But I think the hardest piece is I have a daughter in college, right?
我的意思是，我这么问是因为我自己也在应付这事。我知道。你这个大笨蛋。我喜欢你那几个可爱的女孩。但你作为父母的决定可能比我的更好。所以我只想知道你在做什么。我可不这么认为。但我认为最难的部分是我有一个上大学的女儿，对吧？
So I have a daughter in college and I have a teenage son who's 16 and going to be 17. And, you know, it's easy to keep my seven-year-old at home. But I think a big piece of being a person at age is social development. I mean, the depression that happened at the beginning of this pandemic between the two of them, not being able to see anybody and just, you know, trusting my daughter is back in college, you know? But I trust her implicitly. But we talk very frequently.
所以我有一个上大学的女儿，还有一个16岁、快要17岁的十几岁的儿子。而且，你知道，把七岁的小女儿留在家里很容易。但我认为在这个年龄做人的一大重点是社交发展。我的意思是，在这场大流行刚开始时，他们两个之间发生的抑郁情绪，无法见到任何人，而且只是，你知道，相信我的女儿已经回到了大学，你知道吗？但我对她深信不疑。不过我们经常交谈。
We check in. They have classes? She's in class? She's not in classes, but she has small study groups here and there. And that's just, it's terrifying to me, guys. Like, I don't know. And I miss her like crazy. But I just keep checking in with her like, you know, you got to do this.
我们互相了解情况。他们有课吗？她在上课吗？她没在上课，但她零星地有一些小型学习小组。而这，这让我感到害怕，伙计们。就像，我不知道。而且我想她想得要命。但我只是一直跟她保持联系，像，你知道的，你必须这么做。
I know I'm going to sound like a broken record, but don't do this. Don't do that. The seven-year-old, that's because I've got an eight-year-old and a 13-year-old. And the eight-year-old, I would love to figure out how to get into some sort of like a almost like look online for like clean play groups, you know? Like shopping for friends for a situation where she can get that social interaction because Well, we're doing a pod. We're doing a school pod with like six other families.
我知道我听起来像个碎碎念的复读机，但别这么做。别那样做。至于七岁的那个，那是因为我有一个八岁的和一个十三岁的。对于八岁的这个，我很想弄清楚如何加入某种类似的东西，就像在网上找找看有没有那种干净的玩伴小组，你知道吗？就像为她寻找朋友一样，以便她能获得那种社交互动，因为……嗯，我们在弄一个家庭学习小组。我们在跟其他大约六个家庭一起弄一个学校小组。
And we're starting next week when we get back. And yeah, everybody's clean. Everybody's been vetted. And they take their temperature and test everybody myself. I test everybody and I tempt them all myself and I keep them locked in my garage. But it's great. And then the kids, now they can go over and they can get their learning from school. And we hired this friend's sister who's an out-of-work teacher to come and be, to help them.
我们下周回去时就开始。而且，是的，每个人都很干净。所有人都经过了审查。他们自己量体温并给所有人测试，我自己测试每个人，我自己给他们测体温，然后把他们锁在我的车库里。但这太棒了。然后孩子们，现在他们可以过去，可以从学校获取知识。我们雇了朋友的这个失业老师姐姐来，来帮忙。
And because the first part of the pandemic, the kids were, like you said, they were going crazy. They couldn't see their friends. And they also didn't want, they had me or their mom, both of us were like over their shoulders and they're like, oh, like they didn't want to take direction and schoolwork from us. Oh, by the way, well, like also no one's talking about this, which is families that are divorced. Like this is really stressful. Very stressful. Really stressful.
因为在大流行的第一阶段，孩子们，就像你说的，他们快疯了。他们见不到朋友。而且他们也不希望，他们有我和他们妈妈，我们两个都在他们耳边唠叨，他们就觉得，哦，就像他们不想接受我们的指导和学业。哦，顺便说一句，还有，也没有人在谈论这个，那就是离异家庭。这真的压力很大。压力非常大。压力真的很大。
And if you don't have a good relationship with your ex partner, it is, I mean, I know people who are losing their minds over fighting on top of fighting. And it's really, really stressful. And stressful on the kids so much. And on them too, there's a big, there are so many mental health implications here. We're really lucky that we bubbled up together and we're good friends. We live on the same street and all that kind of stuff. But there are a lot of people, that's not the case.
如果你和前伴侣关系不好的话，那简直是——我知道有人因为在争吵之上还要争吵而快要疯掉了。这真的，真的很让人有压力。而且对孩子们的压力也很大。对他们来说也是，这里面有很多心理健康的负面影响。我们真的很幸运，能聚在一起形成一个防疫泡泡，而且我们是好朋友。我们住在同一条街上诸如此类的。但有很多人，情况并非如此。
And it's going to be a while before we really start seeing what sort of effect this has had on families, like you said. Absolutely. I try to share a lot of resources on Instagram for parents, like Childmind Institute in New York does some online services. That's really great. There's a lot of great sources and, you know, hopefully you can look to people who are sharing stuff. Yeah, that's awesome. So Reese, now you did a Friends Arc. Did you not, where you were in front of an audience, would you ever do a sitcom in front of a live audience?
而且还要过一段时间，我们才能真正开始看到这种影响对家庭造成了什么样的后果，就像你说的。绝对是的。我试图在Instagram上为父母分享很多资源，比如纽约的心灵儿童研究所（Childmind Institute）提供一些在线服务。那真的很好。有很多很好的资源，而且，你知道，希望你可以向那些分享这些内容的人寻求帮助。是的，那太棒了。那么里斯，你演过《老朋友》吗？你不是演过吗，你是在观众面前演的，你有没有想过在现场观众面前演情景喜剧？
It scared the living crap out of me. Not really. No rush, no fun rush. No, I was terrified. And thank God. What about theater? You've never done theater? No.
这把我吓得魂飞魄散。不太想。没有冲动，没有有趣的冲动。不，我吓坏了。谢天谢地。那戏剧呢？你从来没演过戏剧？不。
Too scary. What about Saturday Night Live? You did Saturday Night Live right after 9-11. I did. I did Saturday Night Live twice. I was the first person after 9-11. What, poor taste? Poor taste.
太吓人了。那《周六夜现场》呢？你在9-11之后马上就主持了《周六夜现场》。我主持过。我主持过两次《周六夜现场》。我是9-11事件后的第一个人。什么，品味低劣？品味低劣。
Too soon, too soon. Lauren was like, we have to do this. America needs to laugh. No, you're going to do it. America wants to laugh. Reese, we're just going to do it. I'm not doing it. No, you're doing it.
为时过早，为时过早。洛恩（Lauren）当时说，我们必须这么做。美国需要笑声。不，你得去。美国想要笑声。里斯，我们就是要这么做。我才不干。不，你得干。
Man, you're doing it. Why are you in my bedroom? You're doing it. Will was trying to imitate Lauren Michaels to head up Saturday Night Live. But can I tell y'all Saturday Night Live is the scariest thing I've ever done. It's the scariest job I've ever done that I haven't been paid for. That was Amy's first show. It was Amy's first show.
天哪，你得干。你为什么在我的卧室里？你得干。威尔刚才在模仿洛恩·迈克尔斯（Lauren Michaels）来领导《周六夜现场》。但我能告诉大家吗，《周六夜现场》是我做过最吓人的事。这是我做过最吓人、而且还没拿到报酬的工作。那是艾米的第一个节目。那是艾米的第一个节目。
I know. I was there. You were great. You were there? Of course. Oh, I was so bad. Will, you're so jealous. No, you were great.
我知道。我在那儿。你演得很好。你在那儿？当然。哦，我演得太烂了。威尔，你太嫉妒了。不，你演得很好。
You were great. You were no. Oh, my God. You know what? Some people just nail SNL. A lot of people don't. It's just wasn't me. There was a lot of pressure.
你演得很好。你才不……哦，天哪。你知道吗？有些人就是能把《周六夜现场》演得很棒。很多人却不行。那只是不适合我。当时有很大的压力。
Like you said, there was a lot of pressure. Everybody was watching. You were incredibly well viewed. And you know, there was so much pressure in that moment. And you did great. Are you kidding? Come on. Right.
就像你说的，当时压力很大。所有人都看着。你的收视率高得难以置信。而且你知道，在那个时刻有那么大的压力。但你演得很棒。你在开玩笑吧？拜托。对的。
Somebody should talk about like that. I thought that four to year special was cool. How people talked about what those feelings are like. Yeah. I loved it. It's terrifying. Don't you think it was scary? So you would not do a sitcom because you think it would be too frightening every week.
有人应该谈谈那种感觉。我觉得那个四年特别节目很酷。人们谈论那种感觉是怎样的。是的。我很喜欢。太吓人了。你不觉得很吓人吗？所以你不会演情景喜剧，因为你觉得每周那样做会太吓人了。
Week after week. I'm too scared. I'm too scared. I like you with love. I think you had fun. Well, now look. After you already taken over the world. Is there anything left you want to tackle?
周复一周。我太害怕了。我太害怕了。我带着爱意看着你。我想你其实玩得很开心。好吧，现在看。在你已经征服了世界之后。还有什么你想征服的吗？
Yes. I would love to have a bookstore. Are you serious? And then sell tiny, tiny, tiny, tiny little artisanal chocolates. Oh, Jesus. We'll be right back after these messages. Yeah. Can I talk with you?
有的。我很想开一家书店。你是认真的吗？然后卖小小小小小的手工巧克力。哦，天哪。我们播完这些广告后马上回来。是的。我能和你聊聊吗？
We're talking with Martha Stewart. I'll get the number for your therapist real quick. Because I think we would have an emergency situation. So tiny chocolates at a bookstore. Do you think that having a bookstore would be the best way to attract a chocolate connoisseur? Yeah. Somebody who's in the market to buy chocolate. Oh, I have another dream.
我们正在和玛莎·斯图尔特（Martha Stewart）对话。我得赶快记下你心理医生的电话号码。因为我觉得我们会出现紧急情况。所以在书店里卖小巧克力？你觉得开一家书店是吸引巧克力爱好者的最佳方式吗？是的。那些在市场上想买巧克力的人。哦，我还有另一个梦想。
You guys are going to like this one. Okay. Okay. This is my retirement plan. I am going to become a farmer and I'm only going to plant peaches and call it Reese's peaches. I'm on board. I'm kind of on board. Reese's peaches.
你们会喜欢这个的。好吧。好吧。这是我的退休计划。我要成为一名农夫，我只种桃子，然后把它叫做“里斯的桃子”（Reese's peaches）。我加入。我有点想加入。里斯的桃子。
Because you can't be sad on a peach farm. No, you can't. I probably could. I love a peach salad in the summer. How good is a peach salad? I mean, who doesn't like peaches? Who doesn't like peaches? No, I love it.
因为你在桃子农场里是不会伤心的。不，你不会的。我可能可以。我夏天很喜欢桃子沙拉。桃子沙拉有多好吃？我的意思是，谁不喜欢桃子？谁不喜欢桃子？不，我太喜欢了。
Maybe you could sell the peaches at the bookstore with the chocolate. Oh, now you're talking. You know what I'm saying? Diversify. But the chocolates will be at the counter as people are buying their books. You can get the chocolates anywhere, okay? Relax. I'll send you a box.
也许你可以把桃子和巧克力一起在书店里卖。哦，你这话说得对。你知道我在说什么吗？多元化。但巧克力会放在柜台旁，供人们买书时挑选。你在哪儿都能买到巧克力，好吗？放松点。我会寄给你一盒。
I'll send you the chocolates. Don't worry about it. I just like making tiny chocolates. You do. Wait, wait. You also cook like crazy? I'm not a great cook, but I can cook. Okay, because here's my image of Reese Witherspoon.
我会把巧克力寄给你。别担心。我只是喜欢做小巧克力。你确实喜欢。等等，等等。你做饭也疯狂吗？我不是个伟大的厨师，但我会做饭。好吧，因为这是我对里斯·威瑟斯彭的印象。
You wake up and you don't stop moving until you go to sleep at night. I bet there's a bunch of little yellow birds in your bedroom, though, too, when you wake up, right? Yeah. Some blue ones. The energy of a squirrel who drank coffee is me all day. And I'll bet you never got to be in school, right? Not a lot. You never got.
你醒来后就不停地动，直到晚上睡觉。我敢打赌，你醒来时，卧室里肯定也有一群黄色的小鸟，对吧？是的。还有一些蓝色的。像喝了咖啡的松鼠一样的精力，我一整天都是这样。我敢打赌你上学时从来没及格过吧？没怎么及格。你从来没。
You're the best. I failed, though. I only got a straight F. What? In calculus. Oh, well, I never got that high. I think I made it to algebra two. And now my kid is in second grade.
你太棒了。不过我挂过科。我只得了全F。什么？微积分。哦，好吧，我从没达到过那么高的水平。我想我只学到了代数二。现在我的孩子上二年级了。
I can't do the math that he's doing. I can't do it. It's tough, isn't it? It's tough for Will, too. It's really, it is tough. I went to a math, I went to a, they had like a math symposium for when Archie was in fourth grade to talk about how they were redoing the math. And I was like, I got to go with a bunch of other parents and I kept sticking my hand up. I'm like, wait.
我都不会做他正在做的数学题。我不会做。这太难了，对吧？对威尔来说也很难。真的，这确实很难。我去看过数学，我去过一个，他们为阿奇（Archie）上四年级时举办了一个数学研讨会，讨论他们是如何重学数学的。然后我想，我得和其他家长一起去，我一直把手举得高高的。我说，等等。
Singapore math. It was tough. It was tough, man. It sounds amazing. Rhys, look at fine lady. Thank you for being here today. I'm so happy for everything that you've accomplished in your life. You make us all feel lazy.
新加坡数学。这太难了。这太难了，伙计。听起来棒极了。里斯，看这位优雅的女士。谢谢你今天来到这里。我为你一生中所取得的一切成就感到高兴。你让我们所有人都觉得自己很懒。
And I hope you're getting everything your heart desires because you deserve everything. Sean, you're not lazy. Sean also has the energy of a squirrel who just drank coffee. But then ate two pints of ice cream and sat on the couch. So you can all down. That's me. I need a sugar nap. Yeah.
我希望你得到心中渴望的一切，因为你配得上一切。肖恩，你可不懒。肖恩也有着刚刚喝了咖啡的松鼠一样的精力。但随后吃掉了两品脱冰淇淋，然后坐在沙发上。所以你们都可以冷静一下。那是我。我需要吃糖睡觉。是的。
That was, I think that was the fastest hour I have felt. Yeah. I know. That was really fast. You're amazing, Rhys. Well, I love you all. We love you. I'm just such a huge fan of all of you.
那是，我觉得那是我经历过的最快的一个小时。是的。我知道。真的过得好快。你太棒了，里斯。好吧，我爱你们所有人。我们爱你。我是你们所有人的超级粉丝。
I've gotten to work with most of you. It's just got to happen. We just love each other from afar. Yeah. Do a sitcom together. Yeah. Put me in. Put me in, coach.
我和你们大多数人都合作过。这总得发生。我们只是在远处彼此相爱。是的。一起演情景喜剧吧。是的。算我一个。教练，让我上场吧。
Convince her to do a sitcom with you. I will be all over that. Rhys, you have honored us with your presence. Yes. You're fantastic and interesting and cool and all of the above. And thank you for coming and joining us idiots. We really appreciate it. Thank you, Rhys.
说服她跟你一起演情景喜剧。我会全力以赴的。里斯，你的光临让我们感到无比荣幸。是的。你太棒了、有趣、酷，而且以上种种皆是。谢谢你来加入我们这些白痴。我们真的很感激。谢谢你，里斯。
Say hi to Jim. I will do. Okay. Bye, y'all. Bye. Bye. Yeah. That is such a special lady.
代我向吉姆问好。我会的。好的。大家再见。再见。再见。是的。那真的是一位非常特别的女士。
Yeah. I just, I, Doesn't she make you feel like, God, I've done nothing. I know. I don't think I've ever been that happy or energetic or ready to take on the day. You've definitely never been that energetic and your face has never been that happy for sure. No. I mean, I felt that happy.
是的。我只是，我，她不让你觉得自己像个废物吗？天哪，我什么都没做。我知道。我想我从来没有那么快乐、充满活力、准备好迎接新的一天。你绝对没有那么有活力，而且你的脸绝对没有那么快乐。没有。我的意思是，我觉得很高兴。
I just haven't told my face yet. You never told your face that. But she is like, it is, it's amazing how many different things she's doing at once at all times. She's doing it well. Very few people and doing, and do it at such a high level. She's got the Midas touch. It's, it's unbelievable.
我只是还没告诉我的脸罢了。你从没告诉过你的脸。但她就像是——同时在做那么多不同的事情，这太神奇了。她做得很好。极少数人能做到，而且能在如此高的水平上完成。她拥有点石成金的触手。这，这令人难以置信。
And whether it's movies or like multiple television programs that are kind of seemingly running one into the next on HBO or on Apple plus and like, frankly, it's, it's kind of awe inspiring. You know, it's pretty like, wow. And it inspires, it inspires me to, to, to work harder. I hope so. I was hoping that something would finally inspire you, Sean. Yeah. Me too.
无论是电影还是多部似乎在HBO或Apple Plus上无缝衔接的电视节目，坦率地说，这，这有点令人敬畏。你知道，这挺像，哇。这激励了，激励我，去，去更努力地工作。但愿如此。我希望有什么东西最终能激励你，肖恩。是的。我也是。
Jesus fucking Christ. One more day at this rate. I mean, it's unreal. You wear an R2-D2 T-shirt and you just, the signals that you're sending is just don't hire me as well. This has helped me, not helped me Obi-Wan, helped me anybody. You're my only hope. I'm not feeling the force.
他妈的耶稣。以这种速度再过一天。我的意思是，这太不真实了。你穿着一件R2-D2的T恤，你发出的信号就是不要雇佣我。这帮了我，没帮我，欧比旺（Obi-Wan），帮帮任何人。你是我的唯一希望。我感受不到原力。
Help me. And he just changed my circumstances. I'm doing a Miss Universe project too. There's a script I'm doing with your dad. Oh, we couldn't even get that one out. Please, please finish it. Finish it, Will. Oh, come on.
帮帮我。他刚刚改变了我的处境。我也在做一个环球小姐的项目。有一个剧本是我和你爸爸一起做的。哦，我们连那个都说不出口。求求你，求求你把它说完。把它说完，威尔。哦，拜托。
I couldn't finish it. I couldn't. I couldn't. I was going to do it the last time that you did that to us. You dropped your dad leaving a few times, mid-conversation, which is so rude. I love it. And the guest is always like, Jesus, Sean. Okay.
我没法说完。我不能。我不能。上次你对我们做那种事的时候，我本来想说的。你聊着聊着中途好几次把你的爸爸给晾在一边，太粗鲁了。我喜欢。而且嘉宾总是那种表情：天哪，肖恩。好吧。
Guys, thank you for being such great hosts with my guest today, Reese Witherspoon. She was great. Sean, what a great... She really was the fastest hour I have felt. It was great. She was great. Okay, bye. No, wait a second.
伙计们，谢谢你们作为今天我的嘉宾里斯·威瑟斯彭的绝佳主持人。她太棒了。肖恩，多棒的一……她真的是我经历过的最快的一个小时。太棒了。她太棒了。好吧，再见。不，等一下。
Where are you going? Why are you leaving so quickly? What do you got? Something you got to do today? Listen, Sean, let me just say a couple of things first. Yeah. Bye. Yeah.
你要去哪儿？你为什么走得这么快？你有什么？你今天有什么事要做吗？听着，肖恩，先让我说几句话。是的。再见。是的。
Smart. What. Smart. What. What. What. What. What.
聪明。什么。聪明。什么。什么。什么。什么。什么。
What. What. What. What. What. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
什么。什么。什么。什么。什么。这个剧集还没有评论。点击转写中的任何句子即可发表评论。